[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link thanks for joining us today
that's right it's another interesting
conversation with someone interesting
from the interesting internet
interesting net at the roundtable of dim
lighting this week we have each other
that's right people you get another
rhett and Link only ear biscuit this
week I'm not gonna apologize for that
what you don't have to I mean you seem
like you are about to apologize no no no
and then you said I'm not gonna
apologize for I thought about
apologizing for it
kinda backwards but I can't apologize
for it we've got some dark chocolate
here that I will be eating as we have
this conversation I'm very much looking
forward to I think that right I know
you're gonna enjoy it but I think that
you're gonna enjoy it out there in your
in your ear cans or your pan or in your
car or I like to imagine you wherever
you are being transported to another
word you're it's like you're sitting
here at this table with us so yeah yeah
it's like you're the guest today but
you're silent that somebody out there is
on a bus you're on the bus you get on
the bus every single day where an ear
can you got those in your cans on and
you're like alright time from a biscuit
as I go along and you're making eye
contact with the guy across from you
right now who also has onto your cans
he's listening to another podcast what I
want you to do right now is I want you
to pause this I want to take you ear
cans off I want you to go I want you to
grab him by his ears pull his ear cans
out and say what podcast you listening
to and then he's gonna say something
else and then you say you should be
listening to ear biscuits and then just
give him your ear cans he's gonna start
to try to say something and you just put
your finger over his list and say Shh
your biscuits and then go back and sit
down that's how we spread the word about
your biscuits one interaction at a time
okay here's what I've decided to do in
this rhett and Link only your biscuit
this week I want to explore a phenomenon
related to you Rhett that's me I'm here
and this is it this is a fascinating
phenomenon in how your brain works how
your life works
I guess that not only have I noticed
this but you piqued my interest
your wife has chronicled this you know
in fact today I asked you to send her a
text to make sure I wasn't missing
anything in my list of what I want to go
through and she replied with even more
things to add to the list to do not only
has your wife chronicled and diagnosed
I'll even say this this phenomenon don't
know ah psoriasis but my wife as well
has been a part of this conversation and
we have labeled this this phenomenon
that is not necessarily unique to you
but between the two of us it is and I
think that there's also as we discussed
this it is kind of a discussion about
the interplay of our friendship and how
we're different and how the dynamic of
it and how things work and how your
personality impacts how we interact so
okay I mean I'm not gonna hedging or you
want to ask me questions is it how it's
gonna work yeah I've got a list here I'm
gonna prompt you do I need to lay with
some some things no it's it's not a
counseling appointment it's a it's just
a phone conversation don't need to stand
up okay this is Rhett is an ideas guy I
mean it's one of the things that I've
liked about him in the things I used to
like about things I appreciated that old
but they're Rhett goes through a series
of obsessions like a fashion designer
goes through new outfits and I thought
it would be fun to explore all of the
all of the
obsessions that Rhett has had over the
years things that he gets really excited
about for for one hot minute before just
long enough it hasn't even cooled off
before he's moved on to the next thing
that he's I'm so excited about this this
is the thing and so I've called it Jesse
your wife and my wife Chrissy what I
mean we talked about this and we're like
here you are okay
it's another obsession Rhett's talking
about vitamins and natural medicine to
call it phases phases that's right why
calls it a phase of say oh he's just
going through another phase he's talking
about natural medicine he's reading a
book about what vitamins he's gonna take
what supplements he's gonna take hit
next week it'll be gone it's just a
phase it's an obsessive phase and can I
make my can I give you my perspective on
that oh yeah we don't you already know
that yeah that's not what you call it I
call it layers okay because my
contention is that yes these particular
things that I know that what you're
gonna list I know that I know what my
layers are I may have had a more heated
passion for them at times that has
subsided somewhat however they remain on
my mind in my heart and a part of my
life at different points and I can
access them at any time and some I just
I want to go back and I want to go
deeper and there's an interesting for
some later
it's a layer okay so I have a list of
these layers and I would like
terminology or I mean I've got 14 of
these we may not even get through all of
them okay love to talk I could do a
podcast on each there's no need to spend
too much time on each one but I think as
we go through it there's an interesting
phenomenon that the different the reason
why we call them in a session because
you bring these things to us to me to
your wife sometimes to my wife and it's
well you bring it to me and it's an
implication for Christie that this could
change my life if I if I decide to get
into this - right so it's always a point
of decision for us when you're when you
have your new layer am I in this am I
on this okay and if I am then it could
really take off because it's like adding
fuel to a fire kind of thing or am I
gonna is this not for me kind of it
right because you know I'm a musician
pretty singularly focused on bangs and
so if you get into something well buddy
you go pretty deep right um let's just
get to one okay
these are semi in chronological order
ultra lights
ultra lights yes this see this is a
class of airplanes that at the time I
became interested in these a class of
airplanes that what a class of airplanes
that you don't need a real license to
fly now that has changed I don't
remember what year it was it was about
the time I was interested in this they
were changing and creating a new
classification of airplanes but let me
tell you about this I was working for
Black & Veatch engineering firm this is
my first job right out of college and we
didn't have a whole lot of work going on
I spent a lot of time on the interwebs
and one of the things I found is that
there with these dudes who were really
into flying these different contraptions
and it was all kinds of different stuff
contraption is a great word right
because they're not really planes they
are mostly either a powered parachute
and I'm talking a guy with a parachute
and then he has a propeller on his back
like a backpack that is a propeller and
you can fly all around the world on this
thing well you can fly like around a
county with it so it's for people who
are obsessed enough with flying to strap
a fan to their back and some wings above
them but not obsessed enough to get a
proper license yeah yeah there were
actual licensed kids to money mortos and
trust me once you get into this and you
start reading what these guys say about
it it's like they're say you're one with
you're like a bird this is as close as
you can be to being a bird in fact
there's a movie called
fly away home which is about geese being
led back home by an ultra-light and this
was an ultralight trike which is
basically a tricycle with a big hang
glider wing on it and you're reading all
this stuff over the course of all of
them like I mean like five days
I read oh no no you got to give me more
credit than that I read not I mean it's
not that I'm not read about them for
weeks
then I contacted a guy in Erlin who was
doing lessons but before you contacted
him you were talking to me about it oh
yeah I was in and man I agreed to go to
Erwin and to get on one of these things
I was like how much does it cost you
were like $300 you get to go I was like
I'll go up once and see if I catch the
fever but I'm not gonna really read
anything before I go
but I had mine priced out and everything
I had a ballistic parachute that was
gonna be attached to it like your
personal one not there yeah yeah yeah
because you got a altimeter on this
thing GPS I mean there was a guy who
went all the way from North America to
to England United Kingdom on one of
these things he went over the Atlantic
North Atlantic yeah it so anyway yes I
still want to do this I'll tell you the
thing that stopped me on this one the
thing that stopped me on this one was
the fact that I'm a family man and then
every time I got really close to doing
it is when I realized that you know this
is how John Denver died you know was it
John Denver died in an ultra-light yeah
really mm-hmm
there's no country roads take me home he
apparently was straight down into the
ocean ran into it I think it was a side
of a mountain probably cuz a Rocky
Mountain High joke about John Denver's
death I don't think yeah I don't think
there's anyone who's like upset right
now so I was just like okay this may not
be the best idea on that one but that's
a layer because you might die at any
moment I could get right back into that
I am so close they do it out in Ventura
County mmm it's bits where it's the
place to be yeah it's amazing well we're
at a point where if it can be an episode
of good mythical morning um and I don't
have to pay anything I'm very much in
but I am a family man so I mean when the
rubber we're not gonna die or doesn't
meet the road anymore I really have to
think about that you're not gonna die
the technology has improved over the
past decade here's another one
chiropractic okay now for a normal
person it's like okay chiropractors I
could see how you might do some research
money but but
in that an obsession or a lair was just
a little bit different than saying well
I went to a chiropractor it's
interesting because is it interesting I
these are all interesting now otherwise
I wouldn't be interested in it but I
will say I don't believe I think a lot
of stuff is pseudoscience including a
lot of chiropractic medicine this whole
idea that you're the alignment of your
spine will improve every part of your
well-being I don't I think that that's
wishful thinking and I don't think
there's actual scientific support for
that however and I just but there's no
need for them to push it that far
because there is something there right
right I just want to be clear that I
went to a chiropractor who I do believe
that there's a certain portion of
chiropractic medicine which is
definitely legitimate medicine I mean
they do they do x-rays of your back they
do manipulation to move things and no
stretches and strength exercises and
that kind of thing you know I got a bad
back I've had a bad back since I was in
high school so starting in college I got
interested in this and I was like this
could be my thing you know I could go on
a regular basis and I think in my day
I've seen three or four different
chiropractors but I wouldn't call this
an obsession there was a no you just
said you just said there's a thought
that crossed your mind you said this
could be my thing going to a
chiropractor I thought it could you got
excited thought it could be the thing
that kept me pain-free oh but you didn't
think I'm gonna be a chiropractor no or
go every week and that'll be fun
no I actually thought I was gonna go
twice a week for an extended period of
time but you didn't do it I didn't do
that either because my insurance plan
didn't and didn't have enough visits and
so again I was I was prohibited did what
you'll find is that in most of these
times it wasn't my own decision that I
moved on to the next thing I was
prohibited from exploring it further
what okay and we can move on but I don't
want to put you on the defensive I'm not
being defensive I'm just been like
explanitory I have to say why did it you
know you seem to be defensive like well
I would still be doing this if it wasn't
for something else
and and the reason why is because well
that's the difference between an
obsession and a layer a layer
it's a dormant layer I learned enough
because this is one of the things that
does happen with me I will say this I
love to read write and and I'm always
reading something and I I get okay
here's the difference between me and you
right there's a lot of difference
between me and you as we've established
but it our reading habits are very
different right
I'm currently reading eight books right
like if you look at your bedside or
maybe your Kindle if you do it that way
there's like a stack lucky there's a
physical stack by your bedside right
well but I do a read on a digital stack
right exactly I have my photo a high
photo Maya do you read pictures iPhone
iPhone library but for me like but I
will say let me finish I have not
finished any of those books and it is
very likely that I won't finish the
majority of them because I get the idea
of the book and like all right I see
where you're going buddy
I'm on to the next book and for me if
you look at my bedside or my Kindle
there's only gonna be one book on my
bedside or one book within the Kindle
even within the Kindle like I'll clean
them off cuz I don't even want to see
another book in the Kindle that I could
read you're joking when I read don't
click on it when I when I when I first
got the Kindle first book I bought was
Game of Thrones right like two and a
half years later I was a reading Game of
Thrones
like I would read all the books but I
was committed I'm gonna keep reading
gamer phones and nothing else
until I have exhausted it and I read i
watch the the television show but I've
read every single page of the books
because I just want once I got there I
was committed and I actually felt an
obligation to keep doing it like saying
well I get the idea I'm gonna move on to
the next thing something I don't know
and I think this is a problem for me
that I'm like I can't move on well but a
narrative work like Game of Thrones I
mean you I'll admit I read half of it
and quit you can't get the idea because
you gotta mean you don't know it in I
read well I read mostly nonfiction and a
lot of times you can't get an idea right
but
I've moved on games just like man this
is a long book it's very good it's very
long I feel like if I commit every night
to reading this book there'll be like
seven other books that I can't get to
and so then I get you know I get
distracted and I go to these other books
well interesting once I ran out of Game
of Thrones I started reading like some
nonfiction and it was most I can't
remember what it was but it was most
likely something that you were reading
at the time that you were talking to me
about so then I just picked that up and
started writing yeah I started Game of
Thrones was like this is awesome and
then you read everything and I'm still
halfway through the first one right and
then you recommend later you recommended
another book and I can't remember what
it was but I guarantee you I read the
whole thing just out of sense of
obligation huh-uh no obligation to the
author or the obligation to yourself
because that you know they don't keep up
with whether or not you finish the book
I can't even say it's it's it's a
subconscious thing it's like once you
start something you got to finish it I
don't think there's anything to
apologize I mean I was loved to finish
all the books but but my point was I
read enough about chiropractic to know
that this is probably not a completely
legitimate enterprise and I know I'm
probably you know upsetting people who
are into chiropractic medicine but I was
like yeah you know I'm I don't think I'm
gonna do do this a whole lot okay if
that one's a little controversial some
people have different different opinions
on chiropractic let's go even more
controversial guns oh yeah mm-hmm you
had a you had a guns well my my
father-in-law took us welcome my
father-in-law has always had a bunch of
guns right you know and he's a guy from
the the south and it's not uncommon
tonight uncle's a hunter I mean he's got
cases of behind safe my father is not a
hunter he's just a gun owner and an
elector just yeah he's just a guy who
has a lot of stuff and one of the things
that he has a lot of is guns and this is
really funny because I'm gonna say this
in a way that is as sensitive as
possible because it's in reality it's
very is hilarious my sister
fell in love with Chris my
brother-in-law who is half Palestinian
and half Lebanese she has since been
married to him for 15 years or so okay
and but right at the beginning of their
relationship we a typical middle-eastern
family when you meet one then you meet
everyone right so we met Chris and then
we are immediately introduced to all his
cousins and aunts and uncles who lived
in the raleigh-durham area okay and this
keep in mind this is now first of all
all of them not like in any of them are
terrorists but but this was right after
9/11 like right after 9/11 like
legitimately like we like nine twelve
within the year within the year of 9/11
and we go out on some land with Chris's
family all these middle-eastern guys and
we take all these assault rifles I'm not
kidding oh wait they they had them and
my father-in-law had him I mean just I'm
talking like semi-automatic some some
automatic guns just a bunch of guns and
they bring a picture of Osama bin Laden
because they're anti I mean they're anti
Osama they're gonna shoot this but and
they're gonna shoot the picture okay
good but it was just a weird time of
life you were there I was there and I
was shooting a picture of Osama bin
Laden with an Uzi
[Laughter]
I wasn't there for this and I was out
there on this land in the middle of
Harnett County shooting these guns and
I'm just like this is so weird
but worthy but I was like this is fun
there's power behind unloaded some ammo
yeah right hey you know we decided just
target practice just out bunch of good
ol boys when from the Middle East in
London and at that point I was like you
know what maybe you know maybe I should
have some guns you know and again if
you're if you're not from the United
States and if you're not from the south
it I know one of the things I've learned
in doing good
morning and being on the internet and
seeing all the comments from people
people haven't know they don't
understand gun culture in America and I
don't blame you okay so it's it seems
crazy but I got a gun I went to a I went
to a gun shot went to the gun show at
the NC State Fairgrounds dorten arena
and I bought a 38 special which was a
cop revolver so we're talking about I
didn't get an Uzi I got a revolver it's
it has six bullets at a time and they
revolved yes it's the old style
old-school kind of thing that Rosco P
Coltrane would have had in his holster
on Dukes of Hazzard or Rosco P Coltrane
golf because Ray
that's what we calling his kids this is
where it intersects me because you come
back and you're like I got a I bought a
revolver and let's go into the woods and
shoot it and you should get one oh yeah
and so here's my pointer decision am i
well how much is it that's always my
thing he's like well how much I know
you're into this and that means I'm
gonna be into it how much how much is my
wallet gonna hurt and I realized that my
my grandfather had a 357 Magnum as a
sheriff's deputy right and he's myth and
Wesson he had passed away a few years
earlier and my I asked my grandma could
I have his gun for mainly for
sentimental reasons but then also to to
have something to shoot whenever we went
out into the woods you did some target
practice yeah and I got that thing and I
went out there that one time with you
and it was fun until I had to fire the
thing and it was the it was it was it
was scary to me but it wasn't fun to get
kicked like a mule man yeah ain't
because you're you had a 357 you had to
step up from the from the 38 so well you
had it was a magnum it was a 357 Magnum
smaller bullet smaller caliber but more
gunpowder okay I I didn't I didn't hate
it but I was really bad at it
and it was kind of there was quite a
jolt to it so it didn't take with me it
didn't take well wait I will say it
didn't necessarily take with me either I
never bought another gun and I haven't
shot that gun
um in 10 years but I still know how to
and I'm ready at a moment's notice okay
so should I move on to the next one on
the list here
now this one's related crow hunting yeah
now this one this is do you hunt crows
with a 38 well you'd have to be a really
good shot you you hunt crows with a
shotgun scatter pattern I was not
involved in this no I was on the front
very friendly and I'm at Black & Veatch
lots of stuff happened when I was an
engineer that was ingeniero
boredom breeds recession so somehow I
stumble upon this website where these
guys out in the Midwest are hunting
crows at the request of farmers out
there because crows destroy crops and
there's a lots of them there's no
population problem with the crows but
there's a kind more than we can handle
so there's no limit in some states
there's no limit on how many crows you
can shoot and so these dudes will just
go out and they'll just kill like 50
crows because the farmer wants them dead
they're like pests it's like pest
control but you know you start shooting
that many birds you feel like well we
should do something with these birds we
should eat them um so there's all these
crow recipes now the thing I found now
I'm reading about this is that crows are
extremely intelligent now they're not
some smart as us they are birds and
they're not as smart as dolphins or
anything like that but you can teach a
crow to talk just like a parrot a crow
is incredibly intelligent it has an
amazing vocabulary you can teach a crow
to talk and teach a crow to say things
like you can if you can teach a crow to
say those kinds of things and first of
all just to clear it up a little bit
yeah Polly doesn't want a cracker
how do you how do you know that since
when does Polly want a cracker but go
ahead a crow is incredibly smart has an
incredible vocabulary and what this
lends itself to is shooting it you can
draw a crow in
using its own vocabulary trick a crow
now let me this is fascinating okay this
is one of the reasons I got into this
there are these tapes that you can buy
okay mm-hmm they an audio track where
you can create a situation they've
they've recorded crows or they've made
crow sounds of a certain scenario that
will cause a bunch of crows to come in
so what they do is they have this thing
crows do you know that crows hate owls
owls and crows are arch-rivals do they
eat each other they well they're they're
they're they compete for the same mice
there is a tape that you can get at
soundtrack that is an owl attacking a
baby crow no and so you hear the sound
of the owl and then you hear a baby crow
crying a distress call and then it
brings in hundreds of crows depending on
where you're at oh really so the idea
that you could do this and you set up a
fake owl there too oh yeah oh and fake a
crow yeah right yeah I'm glad you
remember more than I do
well you told me about you're trying to
get me to do it yeah yeah you get a fake
owl and this is a three-dimensional owl
a three-dimensional out and then you can
get the three-dimensional crows or you
can get the two dimension I made two
dimensional crows I bought poster for
instruction but at a construction paper
poster board and I made these things and
so you should put him on a stick and
then I didn't you just jab them down
into the ground and I took it on the
cowl yeah I took a boom box and I bought
a bullhorn and I took the boom box apart
I wired the boom the audio the audio
wires instead of going to the speaker's
in the boom box I wired them directly to
a bullhorn and so I could play it really
loudly if you ever wonder if your
boyfriend husband or acquaintance is
bored and you see him building crows out
of poster board and booming crow cells
from a boom box your answer is yes okay
so but again I'm banned all that means
energy somebody disappoint you first of
all again yeah
so you build all this stuff you go out
you set up the scene I gonna layer the
crow sale I go out with a good friend of
mine from work Sean Collins and he goes
out there with me and we didn't know
what we were doing we expected dozens of
crows that come in we had like one crow
come in and he knew it and he looked
down there news like that's poster board
and he flew away we shot at him in
English was he and so I never killed a
crow I'm sure that's a relief to those
of you who were worried about how many
crows I was gonna kill I never killed a
crow and it's so smart and then it
because I'm just not good at it but I
was so interested in it here's what
happened and this is a this is a
microcosm of what has happened with me
and you within a number of the number of
times Sean Collins I left Black & Veatch
and Sean Collins we just done it with me
had just done this crow hunting he
carried the torch and he became like an
incredible Crow hunter crows stalker
this dude he you gave him your boom box
didn't you I said you can have it and he
got other dudes into it and I don't know
if they still do it to this day but
there was like a little community of
guys who were like home none of which
man in your wake of obsession he was
like created a covey you bought the tape
she made the contraption you made those
things out of poster board you've got
the Al let me have all that and he still
does it well I like to think that he
still does it he's like got his whole
reality he's controlling the crow
population of North Carolina crow man
but that was that was and you know this
that what happens is I get interested in
something and if there are their stuff
associated with it you get this stuff
you got to get the stuff or you got to
make the stuff yeah that's when
something really gives me if there's
stuff involved cuz I want to get that
stuff oh you know what wait wait you can
make crows out of poster board I mean
really okay here's another one of this I
got to get back into that it's probably
illegally this is not healthy I should
not be it's like I'm Condry in the over
the course of an hour I'm conjuring up
your emotions associated every single
layer at one
spike yeah you're gonna you're gonna
explode I gotta go to sleep tonight I'm
afraid of what you're gonna try to get
me into in the morning okay
okay next on this wine pairings yeah
wine pairings yeah uh I'm a fan of wine
you know that I like to drink it with my
meals well yeah I mean I've seen you've
had a glass of wine I would never call
you a fan of wine or a wine aficionado
but I got close to becoming but you
thought you thought about what it would
be like if you became close to coming to
come in one uh once I figured out that
there was this there was a whole world
of people who experimented with pairing
wine with food because that that's when
wine really opens up right when you
start pairing your food and that's what
the menus say yeah but and you know
there are no rules with you there used
to be you had this kind of meat with
this kind of wine or that's what but and
there are no rules it's whatever it
takes best to you but interestingly
there there were these apps in books
even before apps there were books that
suggested wine pairings and I kind of I
got a little obsessed I I did think oh
this is so this is something I could get
into again if there's if there's
something you can learn and sometime you
coming by and something you can do I
mean what about it it was great it in
you know I I don't I don't but the fat
so what about it what I mean was you
were intrigued by the fact that you
could take this certain you could take a
pork chop and you could buy this wine
and you could consume them together and
experience something something better
something better of the better yeah I
grew up drinking milk with spaghetti
house you know but it's just like no you
get this right wine and they interact
there's synergy happening in your meal
right I'm laughing I know this is true I
mean I accept this but so what happened
well what happened was is you know
that's a rather rather
expensive hobby yeah your pork chops are
expensive and you know that's the wine
and honestly you gotta have somebody to
do this with you know my wife is not a
big wine drinker she doesn't she doesn't
really enjoy wine and so you buy a
bottle of wine you break it open and
you're the only one drinking you're
gonna it's gonna be over pretty soon
you're gonna be asleep you know and so
I'd you know I'd we have some wine we
drink it occasionally try to make
pairings but it just this is this is the
thing and I think this is where we're
going with this I'm kind of processing
this okay if you I get interested in a
lot of things but if I'm gonna stick
with it I gotta have some partner
I gotta have to eat them you have to get
into it or my wife has to get into it
and if neither one of you get into it
I'm probably gonna move on yeah I and we
know that and we don't take that lightly
but that's not gonna stop me from
continuing to get into stuff I mean we
like to make fun of you but I mean what
I try to say at the beginning was I
appreciate well I said I appreciate I
said I appreciate it but I appreciate
the fact that you're an ideas guy I
think this dovetails with that that I
would be content to just live my simple
little life and do my simple little
routine and make make the crevices in my
brain deeper and not form any new
connections and to my own detriment
mm-hmm I don't like that about myself so
I like interfacing with someone let's
call that person who says okay it is
excited so okay if I don't like this
thing well he's gonna present me with
something and that's exciting and if I
don't like it well I can say that and
because it'll be something else next
week true and it's great it's true yeah
so if you every this is a good
arrangement and if you ever get
interested in that thing again like if
we go through this list tonight and
you're like you know I'd like to get
back into wine pairings I'm like buddy I
got the app I'm ready
I need to redownload it but water
you've got to unearth that layer and
yeah bring it you've got a toilet
together to expose that layer I would
love to have I mean I had some dark
chocolate and I you know I'd love to
pair that with some yerba mate eh I'd
like to get real experimental with this
mm-hmm
okay no but I I'm open to that but let's
move on all right
there's plenty to go fossils in geology
now I want to say that this is something
I've never lost interest in this I've
been interested in geology ever since I
took a class in college
ever since Ted McKinney gave you an
arrowhead on the Royal ambassador's
hiking trip well that's archaeology
that's not really geology I mean I guess
indirectly as geology because it was at
one point a rock but well okay
smarty-pants
I'm talking you know the layers of the
earth you see that I've got layers one
of my layers is the layers of the earth
itself okay
a meta joke and I am fascinated by the
history of the earth I'm fascinated by
geological formations and I am
fascinated by fossils and I've got a
couple some trial of bites I don't know
how many millions of years of the old
they are I knew at one point they're in
a safe and home at home but and why why
why is it a trilobite or a trilobite in
a safe
why isn't in it why isn't it out on your
coffee table well I'll have it somebody
gonna steal it I have a safe that has
things in it that mean a lot to me and
it I don't have a way to display this I
hope one day to have a man cave of sort
of sorts and you're gonna have you're
gonna take what's in the safe and you're
gonna put it in case yes okay in the man
cave there will be a lot of hawkman
paraphernalia memorabilia what there
there lies another layer and there will
be fossils you can go on eBay and for a
pretty penny you can get like a small
dinosaur skull
fossil really you can also get light
replicas of like a t-rex that I made out
of resin or whatever they're still
expensive but not the real thing
full-size yes really yeah you have to
build it yourself I mmm I mean the head
will come as one thing but I want a man
cave that's got like these up lit
dinosaur fossils you know you're walking
around in a museum
I want that someday what about studio
but but okay we can do in the studio too
but the reason I'm fascinated with it is
because it's it's incredible I get it
it's incredible to hold something in
your hands that lived you know a hundred
million years ago
that's fascinating all that in your hand
I mean I I could uh I mean depending on
the cost I could buy I could start a
trilobite collection but here's the
thing if I bought one I would buy as
many as Merle Haggard records as I've
bought like we're both equally into
Merle Haggard but who bought all the
Merle Haggard records me you probably
said oh that would be cool to buy one
but I'm just gonna listen to Merle
Haggard and I'm like no I'm gonna go on
eBay and I'm gonna obsess and I'm gonna
buy sixty-five records and then I'm
gonna hang them meticulously on our wall
but fossils are more expensive than
exactly so I I know I can't buy one
because I can't buy just one but but I
do respect it and you know camping and I
think we'll get back to the whole
camping thing because it comes to
another layer but I do it dovetails with
when you get into nature and you're
seeing those things IIIi can see that
when I look very close to that one I
turn rocks over all the time I've never
found a fossil in the wild that's a
dream of mine or an arrowhead
I have found an arrowhead it's not a
fossil red that's not a father yeah yeah
it's an artifact so I get it but let's
move on alright next on my list Crown
Victorias Oh buddy Crown Victoria
now when you say Crown Victoria in this
context especially after talking about
like fossils and weighty stuff like that
I think people are thinking like Oh like
royalty or something like all
is a historical obsession of some sort
like this weaned Victoria this is a Ford
car the cop car cops drive cops still
drive them but they used to it's a
quintessential cop or government car and
can i what what what you the listener is
thinking right now is how could anyone
obsession it's like okay I get fossils
wine pairings yeah there there's people
who are really into these things you can
read books about this stuff you don't go
to the Barnes & Noble and find a section
devoted to Crown Victoria Ford cop cars
how on earth could you have an obsession
and you admit to this right yeah I still
want one okay and this is gonna sound
crazy to you listeners I actually back
in the early 2000s created a savings
account a money market account back when
IGN direct remember that then they
Capital One bought them but okay you
could start a money market account back
when money market accounts could
actually generate some some interest and
there comes a point I was I'm gonna save
some money for something and what could
that be and let me figure it came time
to name the account in a name the
account Crown Victoria why because I
wanted one okay now why did I want one
first of all so you were saving up to
buy one oh it I think I called the
account Crown Victoria slash vacation it
was like we need to save some money we I
gotta get a car at some point I gotta
get a new car at some point for myself
because you know I was driving that old
Cadillac remember that yeah I drove that
Cadillac that I had to buy the heater
that you plugged into the AC adapter
yeah the cigarette cigarette lighter it
was a cigarette lighter heater
I drove a Cal was down by your feet
touch it was those were they cold
I drove a Cadillac DeVille it was Burger
D four-door and the heat and they
neither the heat nor the a/c worked
so I got this thing lit cigarette
lighter well cigarette lighter worked
and it blew like a really weak stream of
hot air I was like one foot
so I needed a new car and I saw I
started reading about new cars and I was
like I want a big car with a big I was
always one of the car with enough
legroom and I wanted to sedan I like a
car to do a car drives and I want a big
trunk you see you have those three
requirements next thing you know you're
looking at crown vics you like Google
these things oh and then I find how all
the car with legroom Headroom and room
for my heater buy my gas foot what I
found is that because these are
government and police vehicles that you
can get them in auctions so you can go
to a police auction and you can get a
Crown Vic this still is black and white
just like an old cop car but doesn't
have the lights on top anymore and that
seems to me to be a bad thing now okay
yes you're on the interstate and I
everyone slowing down in front of you I
thought many yeah but it's a little bit
of a power trip okay the guy slows down
and then he moves over and then you go
past him you're like I'm not a cop I'm
sure dude who bought a car at an auction
got you sucka it you're telling me about
the chain drop it has it no it has a
chain belt as a chain timing belt as
opposed to a rubber timing belt which
wears out over time has a chain so these
things are just indestructible that's
why cops have them you can just go you
can chase people through rivers you can
go through creeks you can spin out in
the middle of the median and they're
just indestructible cars with a lot of
legroom a big trunk and a lot of
horsepower and so I really wanted one
and my wife thought it was ridiculous
again a lot of these things had been
tipped a tempered by the people in my
life and that's one of them my wife was
like I don't want you to get a old cop
car what are you crazy but you know we
did interview a guy remember this guy we
interviewed not too long ago for some
position I can't remember what it was
but we didn't hire him though we asked
him what he drove and he said I'd Drive
a Gold Crown Victoria it was like a
former taxi and I was like what no it
was just a gold you almost hired him on
the spot yeah and so like I could see it
in your eye and then he said I said
really and we talked about crown vics
for a while and then he was like yeah
you want me to drive by the front of the
office on the way out I was like heck
yeah I want you to and so when you drove
out I mean we didn't hire him but you
got a thrill so close because of that
Crown Vic okay Wow can we take a moment
and just think about what just happened
I'm glad you owned it what car did you
get when you didn't get a Crown Vic
sidenote Scion you got the silent yeah
which now I Drive a SIA mm-hmm there you
go if I Drive we got a follow up Scion
to that one but you know I got it
because of the Headroom and Al
unbelievable Headroom and legroom I got
it you got it on auction that it was a
it was a total yeah next on the list I
don't remember this one
sailing yes still fascinated about
sailing just last night I was looking at
a book that my wife bought for me a
couple years ago because she knows I'm
fascinated with this sailing around the
world this is a book where a couple goes
around the world and they document there
for their photographers and they
document every location they went around
the entire world it's absolutely amazing
the reason I got into sailing is because
I did some research on what my name
meant McGlothlin
and McGlothlin means master sailor and
so really I was like boy I got to get
into this because I got to live up to my
name be a master sailor and just the
idea of a sailboat that could go
anywhere untethered go around the world
go meet new place new people in new
places
I've always been fascinated with it as
far as I got on this one is about a few
books I read a book called sailing alone
around the world which is a great book
we want to do that I know I don't want
to do that I'm a little bit of an
introvert but I but I don't want to sail
alone around the world you want to go we
can document the whole thing it's gonna
take a long time I mean with the right
sponsor I might be redbull what about
like sailboats okay some sail boats
boats dock copy won't pay for it but I'm
fascinated with it and as far as I got
with that I would like to take a yacht
around the world about that well that's
pollution man it takes gas it cost some
money okay okay this sailboat is
beautiful because it's powered by the
wind and the farthest I got on that is I
took a sailing class at Harris Lake
remember that remember that link well I
remember the class right and I think
what you mean by class is like a
three-hour introductory introduction to
sentient ation yeah intro to sailing you
there was no a class of something you go
to and you leave and you come back to it
on a scheduled basis well I took a call
eight eight class I went to class one
time you you out they sailed me around
there wasn't a lot of wind that day but
this but they let they let us go around
now just as I've got more on the list
but just as a side note it occurs to me
this phenomenon that we're exploring
tell me what you think about this okay
if you did not if your brain didn't work
this way if your personality wasn't this
way I don't believe that we would be
doing good mythical morning right now
hmm
because I remember that the impetus for
doing good morning chilling can was
let's just I let's just come in and talk
about stuff every morning and let's just
see what happens and it would just like
us we were in between projects right and
we had a certain we had a couple of
months as an experiment we had a couple
of months and we we on the way into work
every morning you would always have
something to talk about because well for
this reason there was always something
you were thinking about and then it was
like why do why are we just having these
conversations we should bring people is
this let's bring people into this and so
I said I don't even need to ask you I
certainly believe that we wouldn't be
where we are if you bring it and work
the way it did now I you know I'm gonna
own some part in this too but I do think
that I mean it's an interesting
phenomenon that that was that it kind of
gave us the blind confidence to say
we're going to every morning we're going
to literally show up turn the camera on
and just talk about something because
the you always had something that you
always had three things oh I'll just
pick one that I can talk about you know
I've always and I've always got an
opinion about it so that gave me
confidence say okay we're just having
the same conversation that we had
rolling into work we're just gonna have
it when we get to work and we would
actually be silent on the way into work
and save things for that conversation
and I'm glad that we did that but my
question is are some of these things
you're defensive it seems defensive to
me when you're like well you only took
one class and then you know I haven't
sailed since then but I still had that
book and I read the book last night but
is there part of you that the validation
is not really in completing things but
is there something about just being able
to talk about things is there is there
an ulterior or at least a side motive
maybe that's the same thing if the main
motive is you're you're interested and
you just have passions that wandering
passions but there's a side thing that's
like I just like to know things I like
to be able to talk about things I like
to be the guy that knows just enough
about a lot of things to talk to anybody
about anything
is that a motive I can honestly answer
you did it is not it's not it is not I
I'll admit my faults I have many well I
I don't think that's a fault no no no
I'm saying I will admit my I meant my
faults and I have many but no I don't I
I don't like being
I don't like seeming like a know-it-all
I know that I come across that way
because I do have an opinion about a lot
of things and I don't even know that
that's not what I was that I wasn't
saying do you want to be in no no I'm
saying do you like to engage people and
love to talk to people about a lot of
different things and I'd like to be able
to contribute in different conversations
about different disciplines and
different interests but I really think
you know that thing we did earlier this
year we did this personality evaluation
with Jason jagged and my number one
thing was futurist yeah meaning my mind
is always in the future
and I actually spend more of my time
thinking about anticipating things I
spend more of my time in the future than
I do in the president actually I have a
very difficult time enjoying anything in
the moment and I think that the thing
that you'll notice about most of these
things is that they are somehow related
to an experience that I kind of create
in my mind and I think one of these days
I'm gonna fly in an ultra-light and
that's gonna be fun one of these days
I'm going to sail around the world and
that's gonna be fun one of these days
I'm going to kill a crow or I'm going to
pair the perfect wine with that there
are experiences that I set up in my mind
and I think that I'm gonna have
experienced some sort of satisfaction
and so I actually I begin to anticipate
the satisfaction I anticipate the
fulfillment of these things and so then
I learn about them because you need to
know what you need to know about these
things in order to experience them in
the right way and then what ends up
happening is that life happens right you
end up being normal you know I can't be
a guy that flies in an ultra-light and
sails around the world and has a Crown
Vic and Crow hunts on a regular basis
and all these other things
because it's just you can't do that
there's only so many things we can do
between the work that we do and family
life so a lot of these things are just
passions they're just interests and I'll
just read a book about sailing and think
well maybe when I retire I'll actually
do that so I honestly think it's just my
disposition is future-oriented and so
I'm interested in these things not
because I'm waiting for the wait to go
to a party and talk to somebody who's a
sailor and be like oh I know all about
this let me tell you about this
Seychelles I read about him he'd been
there I think that's an interesting
dynamic I think is in an insight into
you or maybe a misconception of you that
people would say you know for someone
who has always something to offer or a
detail to offer it is okay you could say
he's being a know-it-all maybe he's not
I'm not saying you are know-it-all I'm
saying people could say he's being a
know-it-all
okay but I think it's interesting to
find out that if you if
that you're honest what's honestly
driving is just in well what you just
said it kind of it dissolves that at
least a little bit well I know and I
will say that and we've learned this
being friends for a really long time and
working together for a long time is that
you begin to see people ask why are you
guys how have you guys been friends for
so long and why do you guys keep doing
this entertainment thing you know people
come and go on YouTube and you guys kind
of right from the beginning and you're
still relevant right there's this search
for relevance and one of the things that
we've said many times and Hank green
made this observation when we talked to
him at VidCon a lot of times when you
look at people who have been doing
something for a while on YouTube it's
it's a partnership right and so there's
this dynamic that's like I'm gonna be
interested in a lot of different things
you are going to have a sense of
follow-through so when we decide to do
something it's going to happen it's
going to land it's going to be finished
and that's not something that we could
have ever anticipated or planned but I
think that the reason that we have an
idea that gets completed versus just a
bunch of ideas that never actually come
to fruition is it is is that is the
partnership
and so you know hey if you're if you're
thinking about trying to do I just I
don't think that you can I just don't
think you can do it alone I mean I
certainly can't imagine it I'm gonna
list out a couple of other things here
and we'll pick the ones that you want to
talk about but I will say one last side
note in this is a byproduct of your
friend this phenomenon is I think that
people ask you things like ask your
opinion because they assume that you're
gonna know something because you know
about things that you know about people
end up asking you these things and
there's a lot more of a
opportunity for you to hone your ability
to BS a great answer to things oh yeah I
saw I observed that as a byproduct of
this whole thing or could that be the
motive I just wanna I want to know
enough stuff so that I can be asked my
way through everything else
of course that's I know I'm just I'm
just giving you a hard time
alright here we go I've got 1 2 3 4 5
more things on my list we do it you know
we're not gonna talk about all five of
these okay I'm gonna read them and I'd
like for you to pick one maybe one and a
half how about I give you a sentence
about each one well I want you to you
know and I'll dig it will dig into one
or if you want to dig into one and then
pick one to close with okay so in no
particular order I'll read these out to
you and you can tell me which ones you
you're intrigued to go back to after
sailing I have barbecue hot yoga hmm oh
yeah juicing okay paddleboarding yeah
for weally I'll say a sentence about
each one okay you just can't choose and
then we can and then we can close on the
one that me there's two that me and you
are experiencing together elastic okay
so barbecue I'm really into barbecue and
you know from our song that barbecue is
a noun and it's not a verb but it's not
a grill it is a meat to prepared in a
very special way and I came out here to
California and I found that they don't
know how to do barbecue they think
barbecue means a grill or they think it
means hotdogs and hamburgers or even a
party and I'm missed North Carolina
style barbecue pulled pork slow smoked
pork shoulder and I figured out how to
do it myself and now it's something I do
on a semi-regular basis I figured out
that I went to amazing ribs calm a crazy
guy named meathead he had me to head
Godwin I think is his God when is his
last name meathead obviously a [ __ ] who
happens to be in Chicago of course I
know about this guy because you've
gotten so deep into this one that like I
just limit it to a sin I'm here sorry
anyway I figured out how to do this it's
in it is a passion now to Greek create
authentic North Carolina style barbecue
you're not charlie
aren't using a charcoal
Grill I bought a thing called again
there's a thing you can buy I have a
Weber grill kettle grill I bought a
smoke inator mm and a series of special
meat thermometers yes
and a special magnet that goes on your
refrigerator that tells you meat
temperatures well that's just a the
receiver of the yeah I'm actually buying
that no the magnet the meathead magnet
anyway okay hot yoga again
my well this was a lot of times there's
an experience that leads to me having an
interest and this was making commercial
kings we went to where was that
Sacramento California Sacramento we made
a hot yoga commercial for sandy and what
was his name well I can't remember but
it was it was a Rambo themed Rambo slash
a-team themed local commercial with like
a 78 year old man who was missing a
finger and this is a form of yoga called
Bikram yoga and there's a dude who's
more than a little bit crazy who came up
with this thing that there's these like
26 different yoga moves that you do
under extreme heat like over a hundred
degrees and you go and you said it's a -
it's an hour and hour and a half class I
think and there was you know we did it
with this dude and I was like this would
be great for me I need to do some of the
comedy but then you come back home and
you sign up for a class oh I went to the
class and I went to the class a number
of times and then we did move we did
move to the other side of town and I
never went back the class to the class
once and then you vomited no I went to
the class like five or six times and
vomited five or six times no III didn't
vomit I got very close to it sounds fun
you seen but but here's how but here's
how and again I'm not being defensive
I'm just being I'm just explaining
things I don't do hot yoga anymore but a
number of those yoga moves that I did in
that class I retain those I do them
every single morning for the treatment
of my my herniated disc problem which
brings us back to chiropractic and how
smart crows are yes juicing juicing I
watched a movie about juicing one of
those Netflix documentaries it makes you
think that you can that you can do
something and change everything and so
what I do what you can
do something in change everyday right
that's the definition of a documentary
right and this is I do this a lot I
watched a documentary I watched this
documentary and the guy talks about
juicing can change your life which I no
longer believe that after after having
read about it a lot after you know it's
there its controversial but I bought a
juicer I did something you would never
do which is I watched the documentary
and within not not within 24 hours
within 24 minutes of the documentary
going off Netflix I went on Amazon and
order the juicer and my wife and I used
it for a couple of months and now it's
just sitting up there above the sink and
I would hate that juicer if it was in my
house and that was and yeah I hate it
I would hate it and I would hate myself
why would it was there and that's why I
didn't buy one but why would you hate it
because it I would see it as a failure
to me it's an opportunity I could juice
it at any time right I mean maybe that's
my problem
now I have a juiced since paddle
boarding now
in the mythical show half-hour show we
did last year we wanted to explore some
segments that were outside of the studio
you had had this idea to do paddle
boarding and you'd mentioned in me
multiple times but the way you got me
onboard literally was you finally
through Erica and our management team
got a paddle board company to hook us up
with some paddle boards for free and I'm
like I'm in now buddy and we had tried a
year before you remember that and it
didn't work yeah we couldn't get any
response but s UPA TX hooked us up with
a couple of boards we made a segment for
the mythical show and that was all that
was all you're doing because of some
paddle boarding idea you had I saw a
picture you saw a picture I saw a
picture with I can't a dentist off a
dude
in an incredible location on the
paddleboard and I was like what I gotta
do that how do I do that
and then we've documented the process of
us doing it it was nothing like that but
we've got a lot better but I stuck with
you so I'll take some credit for this I
you know because of this that dynamic
once I was in and once we both had the
boards and it was hanging in my garage
always the kid used that board you had
the stuff I had this stuff yeah so now
we've each got two boards now but and we
should go in the morning but we will
once you have the stuff and once you
have the stuff because your sense of
obligation you read a book because you
think the author is waiting for you to
finish the book you're gonna use that
board because you like walk in fact if
you don't use the board you're gonna
delete the board like a file right
you're gonna get rid of the board you're
gonna sell it on Craigslist or don't
look I don't want to it have that
failure or not follow through follow
staring me in the face and and that's
something I enjoy immensely now and we
both enjoy it and we do it on a regular
basis yeah and four-wheeling the last
one on the list our friend Nick who I
went mountain biking with a lot when I
used to mountain bike now that we got
into four-wheel 8 and it's very
difficult to do for wheeling is like
mountain biking but in a truck and once
you do that it's very difficult to go
back to mountain biking it's like I need
two more wheels and like an air
conditioning yeah and like a couch to
sit on a bike steering wheel in front
but so great yeah so he took us to Death
Valley and when we came back you didn't
tell me it was like classic five days
later that's like for the past five days
I've been doing extensive research on
what off-road vehicle we should buy yeah
right so he had been researching it from
the moment we got back from Death Valley
but he knew not to present to me the
data until he had found a place where we
could get in what which I was actually
just down the street
and I kind of rolled my eyes but I was
like okay this is gonna happen I mean we
had it we were gonna buy you we needed
another vehicle that Bronco was a
failure right it was ridiculous and what
a good buddy and now it's like I'm
thinking when are we getting what am I
gonna go camping you like it's opened up
a whole world for like sometimes me and
my family take the FJ Cruiser sometimes
you and your family take it sometimes me
and you and the boys take it yeah and
sometimes
I guess that's it but you know it's it's
opened up a world yeah that's incredible
how I love it man and I would never I
would never have bought a a truck that's
not that's ridiculous it was totally
worth it
but okay but in so here's my question
for you because we were gonna close this
down in a second
here's my question for you okay I've
eaten all my dark chocolate so there
obviously there is there's mutual
benefit to to this right
I bought the truck what we bought the
truck right we went in together both
because I thought we got if we get this
truck then the next thing you know we'll
be like 4-wheel freaks and now it's this
thing that we can potentially
potentially but is that a word
potentially yeah I think so yes in crow
language do it on a on a regular basis
it do you think okay if you were to
subtract me from the equation I do not
believe say that if you were to subtract
me from the equation fat dumb and happy
you just be sitting there I would be not
dumb and I just I I don't think that's
true
here's why I think that what happens is
is that when you're in a friendship with
someone as long as we've been in the
friendship
you begin to rely on one another in a
way that's just like okay it was certain
aspects of our job
I say don't develop strengths that the
other guy has I see something I'm like
I'm not gonna even try to figure that
out like I don't want to sit here and
toil over this edit or this graphic or
this thumbnail because I know that link
already has an opinion about it and just
let him do that you know what I mean I
think that you end up develop you you
you kind of embrace the fact that you're
like that person is gonna kind of handle
this so I think that you've kind of been
like I don't have to seek new interests
because I have a friend who's going to
bring me a
buffet of new interest on a regular
basis but I think if I wasn't in the
situation you would have in it you would
have developed your own interests so I
hope I'm not but I do I have observed
that there are people like that so I
know it's possible and so I could I
could be one of those people I don't
know does it matter I mean are you are
you concerned about like my level of
self-esteem or do you think it goes
further that it's like it has anything
to it self-esteem I think it just has to
do with I just think it has to do with
just a disposition like do you think
that you should you shouldn't depend on
me to bring everything to the table you
should come up with some you should you
should explore your own things is that
it do you I don't know I don't even
think that I don't necessarily think
that I think that if I would have to I
would have to focus more on
follow-through if you weren't here and
you would have to focus more on finding
something new to be interested in if I
wasn't here yeah I mean I certainly so I
don't know you know I don't know the I
think there's ways for us still to grow
to where we can't we don't have to be
like we don't atrophy in a certain area
like I don't atrophy because our entire
lives don't overlap I mean there's
there's like take being a father or a
husband there are things that are very
much those parts of our lives don't
overlap near as much as our work life
and which dovetails to a lot of our
hobbies like paddleboarding or camping
or things like that
that I certainly shouldn't let my assess
for life and willingness to engage
potential passions atrophy because that
will happen you know I want to be the
type of father that does that that
inspires
[Music]
creativity and a sense of adventure and
my children and so I think I think that
is a good lesson for me that okay I've
got the benefit of someone let's just
say that's you who can inspire me to be
more of that in another circle say with
my family type of thing
and so maybe in the same way the
opposite for you that you know I don't
know what that maybe fill in the blank
but I do I think that's I think that's
the healthy one healthy application here
and I have another one too but go ahead
I was gonna say I observe this you know
now that we've got kids I observe this
in my children most it is most evident
in Locke because he's older mm-hmm and
Locke is just he gets he gets on
something and if anything is I never
realized this about myself until I got
older I started thinking about it but
right like you were telling me today
that he's obsessed with exotic cars yeah
right and this was out of nowhere and
this had nothing to do with me you know
III just watching exotic you know large
on YouTube I like Crown Victorias and I
like trucks that can go four-wheeling
I'm not a big sports car guy right but I
was as a kid you know draw sports cars
and had sports cars but it's kind of
beside the point he found this on his
own this on his own and he's super
passionate about it now but the thing
I've observed is that he will go move on
to the next thing you know he was super
into poking Pokemon he was in he was in
the Legos he was into these things and
he's in the Minecraft right now and I'll
tell you I'll cut you off I know where
you're going it's you're saying well
then as a parent you need to foster some
follow-through that everything is not a
mile wide and an inch deep it's
fascinating how like Lincoln is so much
like me and their interaction that the
conversations they have are so much like
the conversations that we have now about
oh locks like you know I'm in the I'm in
the Lamborghinis now like minecraft not
so much and Lincoln's like this morning
at breakfast I was like Lincoln what are
you thinking about and at the same time
we were like Minecraft it's like I
totally knew that because that's what
he's been thinking about for the past
three
right and that's why I got a certain
capacity for a Minecraft and then he's
gonna be like I'm kind of ready for
something else right it's interesting
the things that even at our age the
things that we're learning have a direct
application to shaping other the lives
of other humans but not only which are
our children but also each other in this
conversation and I'll say the the second
thing is just I think I'm taking with
this conversation just an appreciation
you know that I do appreciate that okay
you're gonna bring something to the
table that's gonna be fun there's
something you know there's something new
it's like I would hate to do the same
type of job every day I would hate to
have the same type of thoughts every day
I would hate to have to come up with all
those different thoughts if I hated to
have the same thoughts so it's nice to
have someone else who is a catalyst for
that type of thing so that that's
exciting and I don't mean to relate it
all back to work but we kind of know
when it comes to certain topics we want
to discuss and give them with a good
morning who's gonna take those things
and why and I think that there's certain
fascinating elements of good mythical
morning that come through because of
things that you're engaged in I think we
can sit here and have a conversation for
the next hour about how all isn't this
so sweet but we should probably wrap it
up a and I would say in the effort to
relate it to anybody's listening let's
do that I think part I think part of
this is that you know if you're an ear
biscuits listener I would hope that one
of the things we want to convey is that
alright you know we're in our mid 30s
we're probably significantly older than
most of the people who are listening to
this podcast not that it's for younger
piece for everybody it's just the way
the internet works and there's a lot of
things that we've kind of learned being
friends for this long and I think one of
those things is that you tend to there's
a combination of things that you that
you have in friends in friendships that
last there's gonna be common interest
first of all there's gonna be like
you're interested in the same things and
you see the world
enough the same way so that there's less
not that you kind of connect with one
another but then I think that when you
think about your friendships appreciate
the differences because the same
differences that you have with the
people who are your friends are going to
be things that they're they can be
frustrations hmm right the fact that
we're different from one another and we
see things a little bit differently
about things and you get so focused on
something and I might have to like shake
you loose and introduce you to a new
thing that could be frustrating to me
and my distraction and move on to the
next thing can be frustrating to you but
those things that make can can be a
weakness in a friendship ultimately can
be a strength so as you think about the
friendships that that you have the
people who are your friends with you
think about the conflict what are the
sources of conflict in your friendship
or your relationships a lot of times
those were going to be opportunities for
a stronger stronger friendship mmm
you know I think that that's that's
nothing he's taking us a long time to
learn that about one another and kind of
yeah like this is what he does and this
is what I do and it's different and it's
good and it but still a little funny you
know so we can have a good time talking
about and I'm glad we had this here
biscuit I'm glad you were here for this
so people you have your assignment go
into your research tonight ultralights
chiropractic Gunz crow hunting wine
pairings fossils geology crown
victorious good sailing barbecue hot
yoga juicing paddle boarding and
four-wheeling and if you stick around
for another 30 minutes I bet you
something else will be added by someone
here to the list but you don't have to
you can count on us being here every
week and next week we'll probably be
with another person we won't just talk
to each other all time but we're not
gonna apologize no we're not this has
been great I'm so interested in it
hashtag your biscuits let us know on the
Twitter and other places leave a comment
on Soundcloud and a review on itunes
still do that it matters see you next
week
[Music]
[Music]